also breaking tonight new drama
unfolding in the United Kingdom as the
country's Prime Minister tries to forge
a deal to leave the European Union
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
suffering a major defeat in Parliament
within just the last two hours as
lawmakers vote to take control of the
brig's of agenda the Prime Minister
immediately threatening to call for a
new general election there which if it
happened would be that country's third
general election in four years senior
foreign affairs correspondent amy
kellogg live in london tonight with
breaking news and legislative chaos good
evening a me hi Brett yes Boris Johnson
a did call for a new general election
after the Parliament rested control of
the brexit process in an attempt Brett
to keep the UK crashing out of the
European Union without a deal on October
31st Boris Johnson lost his working
majority Tuesday when one of his MPs
switched sides some other conservatives
declared their intention to vote to
prevent their prime minister leaving the
EU without a deal in place Johnson
warned if Parliament clipped his wings
he would have to send Brits more divided
than ever back to the ballot the best
way to get a deal is to support the
government Johnson claimed any attempt
to block a No Deal brigs that would hurt
his ongoing efforts to get eleventh-hour
concessions from the EU for a divorce
deal and he threatened to chuck those
voting against him out of the
Conservative Party and the Prime
Minister accused those who would beg
Brussels for a further extension to the
brexit deadline of surrendering if
anything it is a no deal exit that would
mean surrendering our industry our jobs
surrendering our
protections in a trade deal with Donald
Trump and the United States you know
Brett Boris Johnson had said all along
he felt it was incumbent upon him to
finally deliver the results of that
referendum which took place three years
ago even without a deal to get out of
the European Union at long last but now
he says he has no choice but to put put
it to the people have them choose which
leader they would like to send to
Brussels to have another go at
negotiations final twist though brett
two-thirds of mps have to sign off now
on his call for a new general election